it's a friday pft ot usually i'm by
myself on a friday for pftot but because
chris sims found it in his heart to work
on a friday day isn't it fun to work on
a friday don't you want to work on more
fridays well i don't know if i want to
work more fridays but i like working on
a day after a lot of football games that
certainly made it better so no i i'm
going to try to stay strong with my no
friday work policy but uh it was good it
was a fun show today it was it was a lot
of fun it was a fun show and we got some
stuff to address that we talked about
during the show some things we didn't
talk about one topic we argued about
during a break so uh let's let's get to
it i want to start with something we did
spend some time discussing but the thing
about doing a live tv and radio show
you're constrained by that clock you
have to shut up at a certain time you
got to land the plane and you got to
move on let's get back to the new replay
review for pass interference regardless
of whether you like it or not and i
don't like it the reality is it's going
to significantly change the game because
now we've got the ever present
possibility that someone's going to
throw a deep pass
and there's not going to be a flag for
past interference
and somebody's going to throw the red
challenge flag
questioning whether or not there's pass
interference a couple of minutes later
al river on from 345 park avenue is
going to hand out
40 yards of field position last night it
was 33 yards that he gave the jets after
adam gase challenged the no call of pass
interference chris this is a huge
dynamic and i hope they understand what
it's going to do to the game yeah it is
i'm concerned just like you are there's
a lot of moving parts here uh first off
you know it's a it's a subjective play
you and i and 10 other people in a bar
could be watching the game and seven
could say you know six could say it's
past interference four could not or vice
versa whatever it may be so then it
shouldn't be that's the thing yes okay
if there's any disagreement among those
people in the bar
it should not be overturned that
subjective judgment call should be
honored that's my concern okay it's got
to be as clear as what we saw in ram
saints before and it's got to be clear
and obvious and boom not something you
have to study or look at carefully if
you have to look at it carefully it's
not clear and obvious and that's my
concern that you have things that get
overturned that in the past when there
wasn't a flag thrown nobody thought it
was a big deal right you know oh yeah
that was kind of close but you know it's
a judgment call and we move on now all
of a sudden you've got this new
horizon
of calls that you can say hey maybe that
was past interference and the red flag
comes out now wherever on agrees that it
was yeah well i mean as far as the way
it was last night you know and i know
you used the phrase like handing out 44
yards or 40 yards or 33 yards whatever
it may be hey you know the the the the
the non-call on the field was blown last
night you know that's that's the best
way i could say it was applied correctly
in that giant's jets game last night
where we saw adam gase challenge it the
guy clearly had the the hold of the wide
receiver's wrist where he could not get
another hand up there and not just for
like a split second it was like grab
grab
grab grab and he never let go of it so
he had it locked down to where the guy
never got a chance to put two hands to
try to actually catch the football so it
was a correct correctly applied there
but i'm with you i mean clear and
obvious needs to be the phrase of the
year i'm i don't want to see like
ticky tack or you know there was some
hand fighting by both sides and then the
guy who hand fought the last is the one
that gets called as the ball was getting
there whatever it may be those are the
things that scare me along with the pace
of the game um and you know
we'll we'll see you made a good point
about if there's a ton of past
interference calls will they stay with
you know
spot foul right if it's 40 yards
downfield you get 40 yards will they go
to the college way with the 15 yards i
don't know but either way dbs better be
on their p's and q's this year because
yeah things are going to be analyzed
more than ever as far as uh what they're
doing down the field while the ball is
in the air
i think the obvious next step is that
indeed they're going to be pushing to
change past interference to a 15-yard
penalty that bubbles up from time to
time in the nfl i think that it becomes
inevitable when we look at the
consequences of al river on dropping a
flag from hundreds of miles away and
giving a team that much field position a
third of the field went to the jets last
night based upon the review and i still
believe
that the bar needs to be higher before
we're going to invade the subjective
judgment it's one thing chris to look at
the the shot of the sideline and see
whether or not the guy got two feet down
before he went out of bounds with the
catch or whether or not his knee was
down before the ball came out that's
undeniable that's objective
i still think even the grab of the wrist
there's an element of subjectivity that
comes into play here that i don't like
having the judgment made in real time
invaded and and even though you could
argue last night yeah he did grab the
wrist and hold it and maybe it was a
good decision there's going to be plenty
of these that were complaining about
while where al river on went too far i
guarantee you that's going to happen
yeah i i think there is too well i mean
you know al al and he's got a tough job
and i know that but he has not
necessarily been the best with clear and
obvious last year was a little bit
better two years ago it was shaky so uh
it is certainly the aspect i i am gonna
look at and uh we're gonna see the more
these penalties are called and things
and we get to flush it out i think you
know more and more problems are gonna
kind of float to the surface here's the
other thing too is this what they want
do they want you and i every monday
morning breaking down in a full segment
all of the past interference calls and
non-calls that shouldn't have been where
and it's going to happen far more often
than not where a flag is thrown via
replay review than where a flag is
picked up because i think
it's going to be almost impossible to
have a flag picked up because if there's
any contact and they say pass
interference then it's pass interference
and how do you overturn it it's going to
be these situations where there's no
call in real time and now rivera is
dropping the flag and we're going to end
up talking about it a lot unless they
make that bar higher all right the
eagles uh have the bar move a little bit
lower at up quarterback with nick falls
out and nate sudden fell in they were
hoping they'd get a lot of out of
sutfeld in the preseason to make sure
that he would be ready to replace carson
wentz if wence gets injured at some
point during the regular season
nate sudfeld breaks a wrist on thursday
night he's out for a while he's going to
have surgery on friday morning chris i
know doug peterson the eagles coach says
they don't have any plans to bring
anyone in but should they this goes now
to cody kessler clayton thorson
that that that's a huge drop from carson
wentz and we know from carson wentz's
history he can get injured at any given
moment yeah a lot depends on how cody
kessler and clayton thorson have been
practicing what kind of confidence have
they instilled in the coaching staff in
the organization they can get the job
done right now yeah like you said
they're gonna they're gonna stay uh with
what they got and see if these guys can
kind of take advantage of the
opportunity you know clayton thorson he
does have the ability and all that but
yeah he's a rookie so we don't know what
to expect cody sessler has a little
veteran you know presence about him but
not very not much ability so that it's
scary for the eagles because this is
what happens when you're a super bowl
football team you want a quarterback
where you go a backup quarterback where
you go okay if our starter goes down
yeah we might not be as good but we're
not gonna like fall off earth here and
just be totally ruined as a football
team and you know as it stands right now
i think that's up for debate and they
were grooming nate sutfeld and i think
you know he did some good things last
night and i think they were confident
that he was going to be a solid backup
that could fulfill that role uh but
this is a big issue and yeah i think
next week uh and of course preseason
game number three are going to go a long
way to whether if there's somebody on
the street like a josh mccown a sam
bradford i'll throw that name out there
you know or do they just wait sam
bradford i'm just throwing names out i
mean at least what about colin
kaepernick what about colin kaepernick
it was ten years ago this month that
jeffrey lurie and the eagles signed
michael vick after he did two years for
dog fighting right
hey you know i what i think of colin
kaepernick he's a starting quarterback
in the nfl
the whole situation's messed up i don't
know what else to say about it i don't
even know if it's realistic at this
point anyway any anymore but either way
i mean i i know what you're saying mike
yeah he's the best option out there but
the teams want to deal with it and the
all the crap that's going to come along
with it and i think the eagles what what
crap what crap would there be i mean
really what crap would their crap is
going to be we're going to talk about it
there's going to be other idiots who are
going to be like oh he's anti-american
they're going to come up with all this
stupid like
these stupid narratives that aren't true
and they're going to try to fight
against that and the eagles i think are
enjoying kind of flying under the radar
this off-season in this season i'm just
not sure they'd welcome it i'm all for
it i hope they do it because you know
bottom line bottom line you either want
to have a backup you feel good about
behind a quarterback who is injury prone
or you don't there's no way you feel
good about cody kessler there's no way
at this point in his career you feel
good enough about thurston howell the
third and with nate sutfeld out i think
they have to at least consider it now
you know maybe colin kaepernick would
want too much money i mean there's all
these ifs and buts and suppositions
because nobody's ever engaged kaepernick
in a conversation about what he wants
yeah but how could you not at least have
that conversation if you're the
philadelphia eagles they pride
themselves on emotional intelligence
maybe it's time to display a little of
it as it relates to the kaepernick
situation all right speaking of
emotional intelligence or the lack
thereof aaron rodgers publicly called
out his team's decision to have joint
practices with the texans called out the
kickoff drills that were conducted as
part of it said that the nflpa is going
to be interested in taking a look at
these close to live kickoff drills chris
last night matt lafleur the coach of the
packers suggested that he was okay with
that criticism i'm not okay with any
quarterback taking anything outside of
the organization i don't like that he
talks publicly about these things and i
think any coach worth his salt has got
to be pissed off if any of his players
especially his starting quarterback says
these things publicly when they should
be brought privately to the coach well
okay we we over analyze aaron rodgers i
mean you know there's other quarterbacks
who have said things they don't like to
do or do this or do that and i haven't
looked at it like to come up with the
excessive yeah name one balls
one quarterback i will i'll tell you
because it doesn't happen every now and
then it doesn't happen there's nothing
wrong with a guy saying i don't like
joint practices there's nothing wrong
with it he's allowed that's not the
issue right the issue is saying that
these kickoff drills we did the nflpa
for sure is going to look at it it's not
smart
his coach is the one who agreed to do it
and the quarterback says it's not smart
he's saying the coach did something
stupid my point is you're allowed to
have that concern yeah don't take it
public chris look if i got an issue with
you do you want me to talk about it
during the first hour of the radio show
when you're not there and i tell the
world that i have an issue with you or
do you want me to reach out to you and
say hey chris i got an issue with you
let's talk it out what would you prefer
well i would prefer that you'd talk it
out with me but how do you know it
wasn't talked out already how do you
know that during because it happened
that day well how do you know
how do you know aaron rodgers why it was
happening was going damn that's messed
up we're doing this out here i mean
we're talking about the most dangerous
play in football and we're doing this
for me again
yes i understand it looks a little like
you know what do i want to say
revolutionary or whatever but
he's being a leader in a lot of ways too
he's going to get props in the locker
room for saying things like that because
i can promise you when guys walked off
the field and maybe a guy who's had a
hard practice he went holy crap i just
had to run and like get in five car
crashes during a live kickoff period in
practice and it's not just against matt
lefore and the green bay packers he's
also caught calling out billy o'brien
and the texans so you know again i think
this is one of those things that aaron
rodgers just
i respected about him and you know you
know i i know you think i'm a aaron
rodgers homer and all that so whatever
you are i don't think it i know it well
i i because some of this i think just
gets blown out of proportion i i do
chris i don't have an issue with it
i don't think he's got the
self-awareness that he needs for the job
that he has he needs to understand how
people are going to react to saying
these things publicly he needs to
understand he's a smart guy he needs to
understand that by the words he used
send a message and it may very well be
chris that he's intending to send a very
clear message to the upper reaches of
the packers organization and the message
is this you know what you can fire a
coach you can hire coach you can do
whatever you want but i run the show
here i'm the guy that's the face of the
franchise i'm the guy that's making the
money and i'm ultimately going to do
whatever the hell i want and there's
nothing you can do about it i i don't
know maybe i don't agree with that part
of it i don't agree with that now he's a
damn quarterback and he's making 33
33 and a half million dollars a year and
we know he's one of the greatest of all
time and is he a little brash with how
he does that i don't think he's doing
this like almond power here this is my
show no i think he's just like he
doesn't he is self-aware i think i just
don't think he gives a damn about what
these things i think he's going oh no
we're breaking the effing rules the
texans and the green bay packers and
that's not cool and i just don't have an
issue with that part of it you know
again can we argue maybe he should
handle it differently okay i'm there
with you i am there with you but i don't
think it's like a cryptic message you
know towards the towards the green bay
packer organization or a power play on
the floor or the other higher ups or any
of that so you know me and you know i
know we disagree here and
look chris chris either either he's got
the self-awareness of michael scott or
it is calculated and deliberate neither
look is a good one for aaron rodgers
because these are things that not should
not be said publicly all right you know
what i have to run there was one more
topic we're going to get to i'll write
about it at pft we'll have time to
discuss what did you have scheduled that
you forgot you scheduled that you just
realized you have to do something
usually on fridays you're not here right
so i can wrap this up by 20 after nine
because i have a radio commitment in
miami every friday gotcha so because
you're here and because you have to go
to the bathroom and urinate before we
can actually do the show i mean if we're
going to be open about it we'll be open
about it let's do it we start we start
later how dare you say that
why didn't you come to me privately to
say that i am coming here
no one's watching this see ya see ya
everybody have a great weekend see you
monday be good
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports